ja aber jetzt zu einem den wohl seit
corona jeder kennt und das ist der
gesundheitsexperte der spd karl
lauterbach einen schönen guten abend
herr lauterbach
hallo genannt herr lauterbach die
bundeskanzlerin hält die aktuellen
corona maßnahmen offenbar nicht für
ausreichend kanzleramtschef brown
forderte nach der bildinformation heute
nachmittag eine notbremse bei einer
besprechung mit den staatskanzleichefs
der länder soll er sozusagen mit der
faust auf den tisch gehauen haben und
gesagt haben jetzt reicht's braucht es
eine notbremse und was würde das dann
bedeuten
das ist zunächst einmal das würde ja
bedeuten dass wir die geschäfte die
restaurants die knallten die da ist das
leder komplett zu machen ein
schattenriss vor einem jahres gehabt
haben und da sagen hat die juristen die
uns beraten die regierung beraten aber
auch die parteien beraten das ist
einfach nicht mehr ging weil dafür die
quote derjenigen die schon geimpft sind
zu hoch ist also so wird ein solcher
schaden komplett dran also an vor noch
dauern da muss ja auch rechtlich
darstellbar sein und da hören wir halt
und darauf belassen
die juristen das nicht mehr daten dass
das nicht mehr gehen browns nachfolger
als kanzleramtschef wolfgang schnitt ein
parteikollege von ihnen soll auch
widersprochen haben soll gesagt haben
dass die möglichkeiten der länder ja
auch noch gar nicht ausgeschöpft sein
es ist leider wahr also wir haben ja
jetzt acht wochen verloren so viele also
wissenschaftler die eng am ball spielen
wie zum beispiel christian post michael
hermann w oder sondern ich selbst mich
damit denen wir haben ja acht wochen
bleiben tatsächlich gut gemachtes zweig
und zwei gibt bloß eingeführt werden
soll das haben ganz wenige
ministerpräsidenten gemacht es ist in
hamburg gemacht worden aber es in vielen
bundesländern nicht gemacht worden sind
die fallzahlen explodierte sind ja beim
einschwenken der bewegungsspielräume der
ungeimpften etwa sechs bis acht wochen
verloren wir haben beim boosten ist noch
mehr zeit verloren gegangen ja bei der
vierten welle wirklich nicht das
geleistet was notwendig gewesen wäre er
anders als herr schmidt hat ja auch
grünen chef robert habeck heute am
nachmittag gesagt wenn es so weitergeht
muss man in den nächsten tagen noch mal
über andere maßnahmen nachdenken sind
spd und grüne in sachen corona schon
nicht mehr auf einer linie
doch wir sind nicht nur auf einer linie
sondern wir tauschen uns auch sehr
heraus ich zum beispiel arbeite sehr
sehr eng mit yang stammen beispielsweise
zusammen wir sind fast so wie im
täglichen kontakt zu machen da viel und
ich glaube nicht dass da also jetzt
schon also
parteipolitik gemacht werden sollte
sondern wir müssen schauen wie es jetzt
funktioniert die neuen regeln brauchen
dazu als und wird mindestens so zehn
tage
der zeitraum den wir hier benötigt um
erfolge zu sehen und wenn das dann nicht
funktioniert wenn es dann zu wenig ist
werden beispielsweise die länder das
nicht wichtig umsetzen wenn ich genug
kontrolliert wird dann müssen weitere
maßnahmen ergriffen werden dann kommen
wir auch an lokalen lockt uns nicht
vorbei hört aber auch heute wieder neue
rekord infektionszahlen andererseits
sind aber auch wieder hunderttausend
menschen erst geimpft worden so viel wie
seit mitte september nicht mehr
insgesamt aktuell 800.000 menschen also
inklusive zweite impfung und boostern
brauchen wir vielleicht überhaupt keine
impfpflicht müssen wir gar nicht mehr
darüber diskutieren weil diese
horrorzahlen an infektionen die menschen
genug motivieren sich jetzt impfen zu
lassen
wir werden die impfpflicht benötigen
tatsächlich also können wir uns nicht
darauf verlassen dass die dritte
variante die schlimmste die ansteckende
variante bleibt es kann jederzeit
anderen noch ansteckender war ja
bekommen wir haben jetzt anzeichen dafür
dass das der fall sein könnte es gibt
hinweise darauf dass wir eine noch
ansteckende variante hat sie data
variante schon also erwarten müssen ihr
könnte auf jeden fall also im frühjahr
kommen somit also unheimlich wollen wir
aus der situation nicht heraus selbst
diejenigen die games sind die verlieren
will hatte ich schnell ihren impfschutz
wieder es kann sogar sein dass dem
booster impfung der nehmen nach einiger
zeit wieder verliert wir werden somit um
eine impfpflicht aus der gesamtsituation
nicht rauskommen dass wir immer wieder
gefährliche anstiege haben noch mal ganz
kurz nach gefragt herr lauterbach was
kommt da an neuen varianten auf uns zu
wie gefährlich wird das naja gut man
muss vorsichtig sein aber wir haben
jetzt eben ist darauf dass es eine
variante ergeben könnte die also
ansteckender ist es die data variante
und das nehmen wie erstes muss jetzt
geprüft werden darüber wird in den
nächsten tagen zu berichten sein und
selbst wenn wir jetzt noch einmal glück
hätten und es geht mir nicht so dann
müssen wir mit varianten dieser art
immer rechnen das ist einfach also noch
lange nicht also aus mutiert wie man so
sagt sondern das sind noch mehr
mutationen also möglich insbesondere so
genannte ästhet mutationen da das virus
noch lange nicht gezeigt was es kann
es geht mutation sind mutationen die
gegen die ebenfalls resistent sind und
an der impfpflicht ist etwas womit man
immer einen vorsprung gewinnt dann kann
man dann mit einer neuen also eben
tatsächlich gegenwirken die impfpflicht
es daher also noch nicht vom tisch
sondern dass die lebensversicherung
gegen ausbrüche auch im nächsten jahr
eher lauterbach ihrer partei dafür den
neuen gesundheitsminister also den
nachfolger von jens spahn stellen im
netz werden jetzt auch die rufe lauter
dass sie diesen posten übernehmen sollen
denn sie sind ja auch das gesicht der
korona krise waren immer bereit und
hatten immer die neuesten erkenntnisse
parat wollen sie diesen posten und wenn
ja auch kriegen sie ihn also darüber
würde ich auf keinen fall öffentlich
spekulieren es ist gut dass das
ministerium war der spd angekommen ist
wir sind ja an das soziale partner
sozialdemokratische partei ist ein ganz
wichtiges sozialministerium und die spd
verfügt über viele wirklich gut
qualifizierte personen die das
kompetent begleiten können das problem
ist natürlich auch dass olaf scholz
versprochen hat das paritätisch besetzt
werden soll zwischen männern und frauen
glauben sie wenn sie eine frau werden
dann würden sie gesundheitsminister
darüber möchte ich jetzt nicht
spekulieren also wie gesagt wir haben
sehr gute kandidatinnen und kandidaten
also hier wird oder chance überhaupt
keine mühe haben das zu besetzen hier
kann man aus der aus der bürgerschützen
ganz herzlichen dank für das gespräch
karl lauterbach und danke auch für die
aktuellen information